it's important for me to go back and
rebuild the country because this is my
home this is all I have not only I want
to go back home but I want our children
to go back home because
this is the future of our nation and
what what do what what future Ukraine
has without without our children at the
moment while everything is is being
ruined they are born being hospitals
libraries schools universities this is
where the heart of the nation is without
a support of the European Union it will
be extremely hard for Ukraine to
reconstruct
at the same time I I truly believe that
this will be entirely new page for our
country and the Reconstruction will
actually
help us to build a better country than
it was before they were Ukraine is now
fighting for for Freedom Ukraine is
fighting for democracy and democracy is
the main the core value of European
Union reconstruction for Ukraine is not
only about rebuilding
physical buildings it's about
reconstructing or constructing the new
institutions that will work differently
and with the help that we're getting now
we will be able to build a really strong
uh and really truly independent nation